- Oh!
- Oh. (laughs)
- Yeah.
You wanna know who my match is?
Who I would date in a heartbeat?
Go ahead and tell them, Evangeline.
(driving rock music)
- How do you show someone
that you love them?
Tease them?
Give them gifts?
- Do you anticipate their needs?
Do you cook for them?
- Tell them, or act awkward?
- I anticipate their needs.
- I am gonna go for cook for them.
Because I think--
- Course you are.
- Food is the way to the heart.
- Alright, I like it.
- You tell 'em.
- You tell them, got it.
- If I anticipated their needs, I'd be...
- Okay.
- Showing a lot.
- You would pick--
- Beyond that I would
tell them, "I love you".
(laughs)
- Pick a color scheme.
Here look it's a color scheme.
- The purple.
- Purple.
- Mm-hmm.
- Pick a color scheme.
- I'm gonna go with green.
- I'm gonna go with--
- Aww, I know who I'm gonna get.
I just picked green.
(laughs)
- Red.
- Yellow.
I think I would date a
different Avenger every day
if it was based on the color.
- Aww, to date a different
Avenger every day.
- Wouldn't that be
(snicker) just something.
- Okay, justice is simple, complex.
- Pointless, a lie, a goal, a long game.
- A goal.
- Complex.
- A long game.
- How do you resolve conflict, Michael?
You talk it out, make a joke.
- Do you wage emotional warfare, sulk?
- Silent treatment or apologize a lot.
- Talk it out.
- I kinda like sulk.
(laughs)
But I'm gonna say talk it out.
- Okay, and I'm gonna say sulk.
- What's your tragic--
- Hold on I gotta answer.
- Oh no I hit mine!
I thought you said talk it out.
- Oh!
- I thought you were agreeing with me.
- You can change it.
- Can I?
- Can you go back?
- Oh okay.
- Oh thank God.
- That was almost a travesty.
- Talk it out?
I'm gonna pick talk it out. (snickers)
- What's your tragic flaw?
Are you kind of mean?
- I care too much, I
brood a lot, I'm insecure.
- You don't care enough
or you have a bad temper?
- I care too much.
- I think I've been known
to have a bit of a temper at times,
so I'll go with that one.
- I don't care enough.
- I think I'm kinda mean.
(laughs)
- How do you defeat your enemies?
Snarky one-liners.
(laughs)
- Cool gadgets, mental games, magic.
- Diplomacy, brute strength.
That's gotta be you.
- Diplomacy?
- Oh, do Americans say diplomacy?
- They do.
- Hmm.
- It's okay it all just
depends on the advertisement
and what part of Canada you're from.
(laughs)
It's a different project
every single time.
I'm sorry, we'll talk about it tomorrow.
- I'm gonna say brute strength.
- Of course you are.
- Yeah.
- You're the ghost.
- I'm the ghost.
- Ghost.
- Snarky one-liners.
(laughs)
- Diplomacy.
- What about you how do you defeat 'em?
Mental games.
- Yeah I think so.
- Right.
- (laughs) I do think so.
- What kind of kiss is the most romantic?
- The one with Paul Rudd.
- Oh God, I love you Evangeline.
- A kiss on the lips?
A kiss on the neck?
A kiss on the wrist?
- Hot heavy make-out session.
Kiss on each finger.
That's just--
- Weird.
- Strange.
- Who does that?
I mean it's gotta be the toes right?
- Kiss on the cheek, kiss on the hand.
- Kiss on the nose.
- That's pretty cute.
- A surprise kiss.
- Maybe kiss on the neck.
- Kiss on the neck.
- I'm gonna say a surprise kiss.
- I think a surprise kiss.
- That's so sweet.
(poppy rock music)
- Oh!
Oh. (laughs)
- Yeah.
You wanna know who my match is?
Who I would date in a heartbeat.
Go ahead and tell them Evangeline.
Dr. Strange.
- Dr. Strange.
- (laughs) Kay, you got Black Panther.
Hank and Black Panther.
- How do you--
I got my work cut out.
- I think that's--
- (laughs) That's the new spin off.
That's gonna happen.
- That'd be the best.
- What's the perfect fit for a wasp?
- Ant-man, did I get Ant-man?
- You might think
it would be an ant, but no.
It's even deadlier.
A black widow.
(gasps)
- You got Scarlet Witch.
Much like--
- Yes!
- Is that good?
- That's great.
- Is that it?
Much like Wanda,
you're a low key goth
who secretly longs for true love.
- You're capable and cunning
and you're always one
step ahead of the game,
which is why you and Natasha
would make a smashing pair.
- I think it's really
just her really cool hair.
- Like Black Panther you
find someone you love
and devote yourself to them entirely.
- You're usually the
smartest person in the room.
So you need someone who can
challenge you intellectually.
- Could you imagine the hot
and heavy verbal sparing.
- Oh.
- That Benedict Cumberbatch
and I would get into, ugh.
Talk about a romantic evening.
- Are we looking for a
sequel with you and Wanda?
- I think so and then we're looking at--
- And me and the Black Panther?
- And you and the Black Panther.
- Maybe all of us together, huh?
- All of us together.
- Where would Avengers go on dates?
- The movies?
(poppy dance music)